Leofric arrived in Stockholm for day one
of a fine Scandinavian tour his
bilateral meeting with a Swedish
counterpart was dominated by the new
British proposals and what was wrong
with them they do fall short in a number
of aspects certainly our views that any
consent mechanism the work to exist
would have to be reflective of the views
of the whole of the population of
Northern Ireland to not give any one
party of any denomination a veto but the
Irish government seems unclear whether
mr. Johnson's plans means customs
checkpoints or not he's not proposing
that there should be any new physical
infrastructure on the island of Ireland
linked to customs or customs checks that
is actually in contradiction to the
papers presented by the UK government
yesterday do you see any positives to be
taken from his proposals I'd take two
positives from us you know what one is
accepting that regulatory alignment
between Northern Ireland's in the
European Union is part of what's needed
to avoid a border with checks between
north and south and that is different
from the position taken maybe two months
ago so I think that is a is a move and a
positive move and I think secondly the
suggestion is letter that we might have
a new deal if you like for Northern
Ireland but beyond the issues that arise
directly from British that we could look
at ways to strengthen the all-ireland
economy meanwhile in Brussels the
members of the European Parliament's
brexit steering group weren't mincing
their words they described the British
proposals as breaching a range of
fundamental principles and red lines
a spokesperson for John Claude Juncker
expressed caution presently Anka
stressed that the withdrawal agreement
must have a legally operational solution
not arrangements that are to be
developed and agreed in the transition
period afterwards
Leo Brad krzepice Stockholm today on to
Copenhagen tomorrow is at least
partially designed to shore up European
support for Ireland's position he would
have been buoyed by the words of his
Swedish counterpart today who said that
it's not up to Ireland to make
concessions but instead it's up to two
parties the UK and the
you to find a solution as bars Johnson
continues to shop his deal his European
friends look like reluctant customers
but at least Lee over at curse trip to
Sweden clarified the issues that now
constitute the Irish red lines with two
weeks left until the European Council
meets it's still unclear how a deal can
emerge Stephen Murphy sky news in
Stockholm